les petites maisons en bord du cher
comme si le temps s'était arrêté
ici le printemps est arrivé avec une
bonne nouvelle la réouverture du parc
floral ce dimanche
un soulagement pour tous soulagés
et puis aussi contente de voir que tout
le travail des jardiniers le travail
qu'ils ont continué à faire pendant
toutes ces semaines où on était fermé
ben aujourd'hui paye pas ce qu'on a pu
réouvrir les passionnés de la nature à
prouver ou surtout avec ce beau temps se
calme
ces petits oiseaux les fleurs c'est
vraiment redécouvre un petit peu la
liberté qu'on a perdu les magnolias
pères de leurs fleurs mais d'autres
arrivent avec le moine mais les
magnolias c'est fini les cerises et y en
a encore il y en a encore pas mal on
n'allait ni là et puis là les roses qui
vont commencer d'ici une semaine vous
allez avoir des roses partout dans le
parc sur toutes les maisons du village
on ne peut pas parler du mois de mai
sans parler des pivoines c'est vraiment
une fleur que tout le monde attend parce
qu'elle est spectaculaire elle est
tellement grosse elle est tellement
belle elle est tellement lourde
on en voit justement une pivoine
arbustes ici on a aussi des pivoines
herbacées un peu répartis partout dans
le jardin
et voilà c'est une c'est une fleur que
j'adore un jardin remarquable développer
sur presque 5 hectares le parc
d'inspiration anglaise avec des vastes
plus sur lequel on peut marcher où se
mêlent fleurs buisson et arbres
centenaires venir respirer en attendant
l'été le monde d'après est déjà là comme
une explosion de couleurs et de parfums